were you guys because I know Kurt was
very vocal about thinking that never
mind yes huge hit but he thought the
production was too slick and that is
something that he said at the time he
may have changed his mind about that
later on had he lived it it must have
been like 1989 1990 and we were cruising
in this van and I think we were
listening to Sur for Rosa and then and
Kurt was sitting there in the chair and
he raises his finger and makes a decree
he goes this shall be our snare
sound and so that's that's Surfer Roa
the Pixies the pixie suros yeah so
that's yours truly and then he and then
that's the there you go that we ended up
in working with Steve so that's well
this is you know what I think I think as
you were talking earlier about um
feeling
uncomfortable uh with this new world of
Nirvana of Fame and stuff like that and
um I think that when things did
become huge that um we all sort of kind
of retreated and sort of clung to the
things that we felt most attached to um
whether it
was weird old cars or going back to
Virginia or uh whatever it may have been
for Kurt but always musically I think
that
um whether it was Kurt feeling like
never mind may have been over to prod
too over produced or something um we had
always um listened to records that Steve
had made I remember when I first moved
in with Kurt I think he only had like
four records it was like well he he had
a mark Lanigan record uh there was
Surfer Rosa there was the Breeders pod
and the Jesus Lizard record and that was
just the sound that we felt most um that
we loved and I think we had probably
wanted to work with Steve before we made
never mind but we wound up making it
with Butch um who it should be
said but Butch Butch fig as the producer
on never mind uh and
and you know what you're bringing up is
that kind of in the background all along
there was this sound that that Steve
Albini was getting with the Pixies with
the Breeders that spoke to you guys and
so my question for for you guys is what
is that sound okay it's the snare is it
is it the recording of the drums or is
it something bigger than that I think
it's it's the collective sound of all of
those
things
um uh where not one seems to be kind of
in front of the other it's almost like
it's to me it always sounds really
centered where it's like the vocal isn't
jumping ahead of everything else or um
or uh things are like riding up and down
it sounds like the sound of a group in a
in a space um and really just natural
you know I mean I think who was it that
talked about distance in
recording yeah but like how dips
distance kind of yeah I
am and so if you listen to a lot of the
sounds with Steve stuff there is sort of
this sense of distance in a way that
gives the sound more depth that's what I
think and it and and correct me if I'm
wrong but but Steve it felt like your
what you were going for and what you
were about was you wanted the band to
sound like the band you wanted them to
sound like this is how they sound when
they're in a room and they're together
and something real is happening you want
it you don't want all that separation
you don't want double tracking you don't
want a lot of faler and nonsense well
there is a I mean there's seems to be
set setting up as a kind of a compare
and contrast between me and Butch Vig
and I I should point out that Butch
vig's production aesthetic and his like
approach as an engineer was like formed
in precisely the same way that mine was
doing budget records for dead broke
bands uh in a short amount of time like
trying to be as efficient as possible
with with not just with the time but
with the materials and like you know you
you're hitting your snare drum head so
hard we're GNA have to buy a new snare
drum head you know so like uh let me let
me put some gaffer on there or something
to keep so that we don't split the snare
drum head that like his aesthetic and
his techniques are very much in the same
school as mine I have a ton of respect
for Butch he and I I felt a kind of
friendly competition with him before he
started making big famous records before
he made records with bands like Nirvana
he and I were making records with a lot
of the same bands like Kindred bands
they would do one record with me and one
record with butch or like you know uh
like he would do a kilder record and a
decen record and then I would do a
kilder record and a deiton record like
that it was like the same clientele the
same peer group the same circles um and
what the thing that I remember most
about the Nirvana Butch connection is
that when we got to the studio to start
work
on um the inudo album Kurt had a
cassette of the rough mix that Butch had
given him of the nevermind sessions it
wasn't the finished album that was in
the stores it was the cassette of of the
tracks that Butch had done without any
like fanciful mixing without any like
yeah just like these are the track s and
he played that to get familiar with the
sound of the studio he played it through
the speakers and I thought it sounded
fantastic do you guys know what
I'm do you remember that no I thought it
sounded great and I don't
remember forgive me I don't remember
hearing the the nevermind album and
thinking this sounds great it
didn't bring to mind any of the records
that Butch had done that I was familiar
with that were the records that made his
reputation and probably made Nirvana
want to work with him in the first place
so to to be fair to just go back to that
time we've you know never mind is out
they're they're the biggest band in the
world they're looking to make their
follow-up album um at that time what did
you were you a fan were you a fan of
Nirvana I wasn't super familiar with
Nirvana I had heard like the ubiquitous
stuff that everyone that was being
played on the radio and all the clubs
and like every gig you would go to as
you were loading in the sound guy would
put never mind on to crank the PA and
balance the PA so I had heard the album
many times sort of secondhand right I
wasn't a student of Nirvana I was
familiar with their circle like all the
other bands in Seattle that they were
like you know Compadres with like the
Melvin and the mud honey and all those
other bands I like I knew those bands
and I was familiar with the sound but I
couldn't admit to being a fan I became a
fan of Nirvana through the process of
working with them and seeing them in
action firsthand because I'd never seen
them play live if I had ever seen him
live I'm certain I would have become a
fan you know what's amazing is so the
decision is made we would like Steve
Albini to produce this record and most
people I think anyone else on the planet
in that position would have said please
please please please please and you
write this letter when you find out that
they're interested and this letter is
not a please hire me letter it's a great
letter so but it is it is a it is
a I'll do it but here are my conditions
letter which is really which is imp
first of all this is sounds like that
ethereum thing a little bit it is I mean
it really is a uh um it is a it's a bit
of a screed about what you believe and I
will do this if you do it on my terms
and if you're willing to do it and then
you shockingly say I'm not taking points
on this record I I don't want to do that
you Saidi want to be paid like a plumber
just give me some money up front but you
thought it was immoral to get points in
the record yeah I mean I the the the way
that record producers and recording
people are compensated in at that time
in particular was a trick of accounting
that shifted the cost away from the
label and toward the band made the band
ultimately responsible for whatever the
producer got paid and and it didn't come
out of the general proceeds of the
record the way it would in an
independent labels contract for example
it came specifically out of the money
that would otherwise have gone to the
band like literally every dollar I would
get paid would mean that was a dollar
that Dave didn't get or Chris didn't get
or Kurt didn't get I mean that's just
the way the that's the way the
accounting works in those kinds of deals
and I've I think that's ethically
untenable I don't I and I I'll admit
that I think less of people who opt to
do things that way I think it's I think
it's on its face it's absurd like I work
on a record for a few days and then for
the rest of your life you have
to keep paying me like you get me a give
me a chip off of every nickel that you
earn like you to talk to my agent and my
manager if you would if you could
convert them to that
view